are you familiar with thucydides trap no
it's a
it's this concept that whenever a rising
economic power
is about to displace the dominant
economic power war eras
and there's been for at least a decade
now fear that that's going to happen
between the us and china
particularly with the constant cyber
warfare that's been going on for some
time
then you've got the the strike strike
the chinese strike groups going through
the the straight
straight of taiwan i believe it's called
and their claim to the south china sea
the sinking of vietnam vietnamese boats
the expanding of the military into the
south china sea
into the atolls and recently we had uh
an elephant walk in guam and the the
i think um the us retreated
our our military forces and brought them
back to the u.s
there was a fear that china could have
wiped out our entire you know
that entire force so there's real
concerns that with china taking hong
kong
right now they're doing beaching drills
which people assume is is
mostly about seizing taiwan that if the
u.s can't maintain that control
china's economic growth will eventually
displace the u.s and
they're on track for 2028 i believe
right now and then
war well if they go to war with
us it would destroy their economy now it
may be that they don't care about that
but and then if we say that their
economy will displace ours
no it would be potentially bigger in a
backwards number like gdp
terms but china's a desperately poor
country relative to us they'll still be
exponentially poorer than we are
in 2020 their per capita income right
now is what 4 000 a year
an aliquippa pa that poor depressed
american city it's over 20 000.
so it's still a very poor country uh
but again if they grow richer they will
grow richer because the us
becomes quite a bit richer but isn't
that per capita gdp just based on the
fact that the authoritarian government
is authoritarian i mean they've got more
millionaires in china
for i mean for an obvious reason as well
they got substantially more people when
has the state ever been able to build an
economy like that we know
authoritarianism from the 20th century
we know what it looked like it smelled
intensely it was
lines for shoes that didn't fit and that
you didn't want
what did pj o'rourke always say that
bulgarian blue jeans ended the cold war
china is not authoritarian in the way
that it
what the communist world was in the 20th
century where the people were
desperately
hungry deprived miserable
to go to china is to go to a very modern
place again i'm not defending every
aspect
about it but i think it's a mistake to
say that they're authoritarian in the
way that the former soviet union was or
that cuba is today or that north korea
is i mean
in what sense though they currently have
concentration camps
they would argue that we do too that
doesn't that this is not me bastard
i love the united states the chinese
always wonder well the us treated
indians in a certain way they treated
black people in a certain way
uh why is it that we're criticized for
for
for certain things that we do again i'm
not defending because they're doing them
now
like guantanamo and because they have
nuclear weapons and because they're
growing such a rate that
if there is right now a country that
currently thinks it's okay to
engage in the formation of concentration
camps and ethnic genocide
and as another country the united states
the dominant superpower which doesn't
agree with that and that's inherently
better than the other
why would we let a country that supports
genocide and concentration camps
take over the global economy and
challenge our authority
they can't a country can't take over a
global economy it's it's people within
it
the us is the biggest economy most
prosperous economy in the world but if
you went to
again burkettsville maryland would you
think that i mean
there are parts of the the us that are
very rich there are parts of the u.s
that are desperately poor
same with china it's not a country thing
so
but if china the more china grows rich
by definition its wealth redounds to us
because if they're not
by virtue of getting rich that means
that they're improving our lives by
selling us things that we need which
allows us to specialize or they're
gaining influence over our
country's leaders who then pass laws
favorable to china which suppress our
rights
case in point when hong kong was being
essentially taken over by china
you couldn't buy a custom jersey from
the nba that said free hong kong they
banned it
people like mark cuban and steve kerr
came out in defense of chinese
authoritarianism why
because they were in on the take if
china grows powerful
and they gain access to all these
resources they start making more money
because they make our medicine because
they make most of our you know many of
our basic goods that we can't
manufacture anymore
then at a certain point you are going to
see our we we have our politicians
we have joe biden flying his son on air
force two to china for a private equity
deal
and then they're going to be deferential
to chinese authoritarianism as opposed
to american constitutionalism and then
one day you'll wake up and find
that you have politicians saying things
like we should allow the chinese way of
life into our universities which we have
a thousand talents program
you're gonna end up with people like
mark cuban a prominent tv personality
advocating on behalf of joe biden to get
elected and advocating against the first
amendment our own constitutional rights
what's what we thought was going to
happen was that opening up china and
expanding
our you know our trade deals there was
this idea among this neoliberal
uh group of global politicians that
trade lines
will end war i heard it from uh penn
gillette actually and he's a
i believe he's active in the cato
institute he said what ended war between
britain great the great great britain
and france or england and france was
economics they realized they could all
become much better off and wealthier
but to a certain degree they have a very
different culture for a certain amount
of time but then they also share certain
values namely religious values and basic
moral framework
the united states does not share a moral
framework with chinese communism
so as china gains more power we thought
they would become more like us
in fact the opposite is true do you
think the state controls the economy in
china
i think that the communist party has
tendrils in all of their major
corporations
what are you worried about then based on
based on what you're saying they're not
a threat economically
because unless the chinese are
genetically superior in such a way that
their businesses
can somehow survive the state wanting to
control what they do and we know here
that the state is limited by the known
you guys are planning an all new way of
doing things economically
that politicians would be surprised
about because they've never even heard
of it
so unless the chinese are somehow unique
what you're describing
signals their eventual decline
economically i i don't think so
they're what they're doing is they're
allowing capitalistic enterprise
while making sure that certain certain
things that would threaten their
structures
can't exist so for instance we see this
now in the us in many ways
if you say the wrong opinion or even the
wrong name
on these platforms you'll be eliminated
you you say complementary things you
know we're talking about doing a sitcom
we're talking about spanning and
producing culture
at any moment any one of these the any
any part of the infrastructure
the chain links that allows us to exist
could ban us for an arbitrary reason
and we see it all the time people get
erased from the internet their opinions
are not allowed to exist
and there's an attempt by this dogmatic
cult to create a monoculture in this
country
very similar to what we see in china so
when china with the chinese communist
party did that was
was brilliant when they watched the
collapse of the soviet union
when they watched the failures of the
fascists they realized you know what
works
allow capitalistic systems to function
to a certain degree
and then make sure we have a place to
stop anything that would challenge our
ultimate authority and power
we want businesses to grow and flourish
but at a certain point we see something
that would upend
our power we shut it down so what
happens in china
censorship if you go online and say
there was a you know we
we had this viral video where a guy was
buckled to a chair and beaten by police
for saying he didn't like police so sure
they have mcdonald's
they also get their doors welded shut
when they get sick and then they die
they're treated like like things part of
a hive instead of individuals
what's scary then is in the us as more
and more of our
our our wealthy individuals our
millionaires our billionaires
and the lobbyists who are funded by them
started getting special favor from china
started having investments in china they
became deferential to china
you'll see these billionaires who would
say if i come out and say free hong kong
i might lose a million dollars this year
so i won't do it
in fact if i allow people to buy a nba
jersey that says free hong kong
china will get mad at me and will lose
our nba contract so i won't allow that
now americans were actually barred from
saying free hong kong
that's that's a value that we hold dear
in in in terms of our history
with classical liberalism freedom of the
individual and the consent of the
governed
china doesn't respect that the more
power they gain economically over our
industries and our politicians
the more those politicians are going to
keep deferring to china
and then come 2028 when their economy
displaces ours there are going to be
substantially there's gonna be a
substantially large amount of very
wealthy individuals
flooding money all throughout the united
states to pass laws that suppress the
rights of american citizens
now the chinese communist party has
their party branch and all of these
all of these companies in china if you
want to open a google
office in china the communist party gets
a branch well in the united states we're
getting something similar
with the office of diversity inclusivity
and equity
this cult-like ideology of leftist
identitarianism
which functions in a much in a very very
similar way
and it seems in many ways deferential to
china
so my fear is if the united states
continues down a path
of culturelessness or cultural
stagnation
and we keep deferring to hey we all make
money when china makes our vitamin c and
our antibiotics
eventually china is just going to have
all the money and they're going to be
able to pay people off
and it's been happening and it's working
and it's bad for us
case in point the numerous amount of of
university professors
who were arrested and charged with
taking money from china
without telling the us government so you
had professors who are getting grants
from the us government
and then also secretly taking money from
the chinese communist party
essentially or allegedly to then give
american research to china
so we pay for it the american taxpayer
the the american labor
and then china uses it to exploit us
they then gain more economic influence
they then give incentives to our
millionaires and our billionaires
who then turn around and tell all of
these local politicians all the
they pay for these commercials and they
run propaganda and politicians that
suppress
our rights and take away from us if this
keeps continuing
eventually china will will will stage
will actually uh invade taiwan joe biden
won't be able to do anything about it
the rest of the world will say the us is
unable to protect its allies
and then china becomes the global
dominant power and then when you talk
about all this wonderful american
culture that spreads across the globe
it will start changing into chinese
communist culture then in the united
states which we're already seeing calls
for banning hate speech
they're going to be people who end up in
prison and beaten for saying the wrong
thing
once we start losing our constitutional
rights and we are then how long until we
just clap and cheer and watch as china
takes over
and we just do what they want well
because what you're saying
once again can't happen if the state's
planet you're saying the chinese can
control
the future they can control businesses
but implicit there is that they know
what the businesses of the future will
be
we see that as folly all the time in the
united states let's never forget that
back in 2005 blockbuster wanted to merge
with movie gallery the ftc said no
to dominant in home rental video so out
of nowhere comes netflix
and wipes them out if you go back to
2000 time warner wanted to merge with
aol
government held that up for a year that
was going to be too powerful of an
industry you know there's no way if if
that's
that they're going to have full control
oh yeah within a few years that merger
aol was wiped from the masthead
back in the 1960s the view was that if
gm
isn't controlled isn't isn't constrained
by government a little bit more they're
going to own the whole car industry
by 2008 that same federal government was
bailing them out
so by definition when government tries
to
control business it is controlling the
past once the government discovers you
as worthy of plucking for money once it
discovers the billionaires worthy of
plucking
they've discovered the past remember i
submit to you
microsoft in the late 90s that was
another allegedly impermeable
monopoly except for that it was unaware
of the power of the internet is the
unaware of the power of search is they
know where the power of of the
smartphone
is unaware of the power list goes on and
on
so implicit here is that the chinese
once again
have a sense of what the future is they
don't
and so if they are trying to control
industry
they will by definition limit industries
growth and they will not become the
economic power you think unless they
have a super powered gene
that the world has never seen before but
i didn't say that i didn't say they know
what's going to succeed
but you implied that they can control
the businesses
and they will limit them in certain ways
so as a way
to limit their their their ability to
grow in such a way that would threaten
the communist parties
right existence yes so based on that
in the us what the federal government
would have done is come after microsoft
once again would have come after
blockbuster because you know it was so
powerful
would have come after come after time
warner and aol
government is always looking in the past
and so every time if that's what the
chinese government's doing
once again i've got you've got nothing
to worry about because the businesses
that are going to be dominant in china
in the future
are not the ones today and that's the
same thing here if you have me back in
five years or 10 years
how much do you want to bet that
microsoft apple
amazon google and facebook aren't the
five most valuable companies in the
world
i'll put any amount of money on that
perhaps
but how do you explain than the fact
that already we are seeing
american industrialists support chinese
communism over american
constitutional liberalism or or
classical liberalism not liberal in the
political sense
well for one i think once again for the
typical chinese they don't experience
government authoritarianism on a daily
basis this is not to defend but let
can we at least to some degree admit
that when we talk about the uh
the dissidents in china and and we
defend them and we get
behind them it's kind of a rich man's
concept
it's a paris los angeles new york
concept do you think the typical chinese
knows about these dissidents
they don't right so the the great
firewall in the suburbs
it's not a simple unable to fight back i
don't think so i think you'd find the
same thing here
go to aliquippa pa and see how many
people could have this conversation with
you i don't think it's
as much suppression because anyone who's
at all good with computers in china
can get beyond the firewall it's so easy
every time i've been to china you got a
vpn you can be on
you can get any information you want do
they suppress tiananmen square you
better believe it
but if you if you have passable
knowledge of computers in china you can
get all the information you want about
it
and so it's the same thing there the
typical chinese is just too busy trying
to make a living
to worry about this isn't me defending
it but i think this
notion that they're all repressed people
is belied by what exists over there this
if it were that repressive it couldn't
be that gleaming of a country
in many ways with buildings going up and
all sorts of economic
opportunity why do u.s businesses kowtow
look it's a huge market and why is it a
huge market
it is because the people there are
increasingly free to produce
in very entrepreneurial ways so long as
it doesn't
challenge the authority of the chinese
communist party and their goals thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content
segments you can't get anywhere else go
to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you